العام اللي فات انا كنت بسوريا يعني كنت
بالحرب يعني شفت الحرب شفت اللي صار
بسوريا هلا لما بلشوا السوريين
والفلسطينيين يوصلوا بعد اللي صاير
بسوريا فانا فلسطيني سوري اساسا فهد الناس
بيسوني يعني ف وجابرييل صديقي اللي هو
الصحفي الايطالي هو شغلته هو اختصاص يعني
هو مختص بقضايا المهاجرين فانا وهو كنا
نجتمع مع بعض نطلع على محطه ميلانو اللي
هي بيجتمعوا فيها كل المهاجرين وبنحاول
نساعد الناس باللي بنقدر عليه يعني حدا
بده يستفسر عن شيء في مره بدها تتحمم في
اطفال ما بعرف يعني هي القصص الى يوم وصل
عبد الله اللي هو العريس بالفيلم تبعنا
فوصل وعم يسالنا يعني هيك شافنا عم نحكي
عربي اج عننا سالنا انه وين القطار اللي
بروح على السويد عرفتي
كيف حقيقه طبعا هو الفيلم يعني كل شي صار
حقيقه انا ضليت شي ساعه مسيني بين الجسر
موني بالسفينه وصاروا يحطوا العالم الميتي
فوقي يعني ما غرقت بالبحر يمكن اختنق بين
الجسد فنحن عزمنا على قهوه ضحكنا انه ما
في قطار بيطلع اسويد مباشره يعني اي
وعزمنا على قهوه وسمعنا قصته لانه عبد
الله هو واحد من الناجين من مركب ماتوا في
225 واحد واللي طلعوا 26 واحد كان جاي من
ليبيا وهو شاف يعني شاف هذا الموت بعينه
وطلعوه من البحر على اساس انه هو جثه يعني
بيحكي بالفيلم قصته انه لما حسن يحرك ايده
انتبهوا انه هو مش ميت فطلعوا شالوه من
بين الجثس يعني فكانت قصته كثير اسيه فاجت
الفكره انه نحن نسجل بس يعني للمستقبل
نسجل الفيديو لهذا
الشيء والله العظيم نشوف عالم ثبتوه
بالارض هيك الدم يطلع من من ايديه فاضطروا
انه يتعاملوا مع مهربين مره اخرى يعني بعد
ما هم دفعوا تهريب وعبروا بمراكب الموت
وصلوا الى ايطاليا لازم يدفعوا كمان مصاري
مره ثانيه ويعملوا رحله يعني رحله ثانيه
بالسيارات بالقطارات مع مهربين او مشي على
الاقدام احيانا حتى يوصلهم والمهاجرين مثل
ما بالفيلم بينحكى يعني المهاجرين ال
المهربين عف هم تجار بشر ما عندهم اي
اخلاق عندهم اي انسانيه يعني فعلا هي
القضيه صارت انه في
عائلات سوريا اتاخدت على اساس انه على
السويد دافعين المصاري وكل شي المهاجرين
تركوهم بجبال الب مثلا انه في ثلج وكذا ان
ها السويد يلا انزلوا سلطه واللي هي ساعه
عن ميلانو يعني ما عملوا شي هي ات من هون
فكيف بنا نساعد ها الناس فكرنا هيك نعمل
عرس وناخذ مركب عرس مين بيوقف مركب عرس م
ليش وقف مركب عرس
طبعا في منهم لا بيسرقوا وقفوك بالسياره
بيجي مهربين اخرين بيسرقوا المصاري اللي
معي وكذا زدوك بالشارع فه القضايا كلياتها
يتعرضوا عليها ليش لانه بسبب هذا اللي عم
يصير هذا عدم الالتزام بالقانون وهي
الكذبه الانسانيه الكبرى اللي عم تحاول
تطرحها اوروبا عن نفسها يعني
ف فكره الفيلم يعني
بعد ما عبر المهاجر مراكب الموت شو صير مع
بابا لان هي نقطه غامضه يعني ما حدا بعرف
شو عم بصير معه الناس كمان حتى اللي هون
بفكروا انه بس وصلوا خلص انحلت امورهم فهو
ها اللي يعني بشكل عام ها القضيه اللي كنا
احنا مركزين عليها بالذات مو
مهربين هلا انا صراحه انا ما فيني اكتب عن
ثوره مع الاسف يعني ما كنت موجود فيها انا
ما كنت جووا الحرب انا طالع من سوريا من
ست سنين عرفتي كيف هلا بنشوفها عن طريق
اليوتيوب واصدقائنا وبنعرف الاخبار كل شيء
عم بيصير بنعرف واهلنا موجودين وكل شيء و
بشكل عام انا ما كان عندي اهتمام ب يعني
بس هي الحرب صارت بغض النظر عن الاسباب هي
في حرب في ناس عم تموت هو هذا الاهم في
ناس عم تفوت في مهاجرين عم تطلع وهي
المهاجرين عم نشوف شو عم صير فيها
بالزعتري وبلبنان وبترك بكل مكان عرفتي
كيف فهي بحد ذاتها هي يعني انا انا بشوفها
انه يعني الازمه عرفتي هون بتصير الازمه
اكثر هو شو اكثر من انه بلد تدمر اوكيم
البيوت اللي تدمرت تعمر بتتعمر مره ثانيه
بس ها الناس اللي طلعت ها الناس اللي
الاطفال اللي عم تنولد بالمخيمات شلون بدك
تصلحي جواتها كيف بدك ترجعي تعمري مره
ثانيه فانا هذا كانت وجهه نظري شخصيا من
الموضوع باعتبار انا عايش في اوروبا وهاي
الازمه شفتها يعني شفت وعشت معها ف هذا
الشيء اكيد خلاني روح عليها وبالنهايه مثل
ما قلت لك بالنهايه ننا عم نحكي على جانب
من الازمه الازمه السوريه لانه يعني انا
برايي انه الفن ما في تتحمله كثير اشياء
يعني لازم يكون خاصه فيلم سينما عباره عن
ساعه ونص ما فيك تحمله كل شيء ففي موضوع
قضيه واضحه وهي جز من ز عيشه كويسه
لاولادي يعني مش بعدين بحاول اجيب
اودي شعيش عيش كويسه معهم
جنسيه يساف وين ما يروحوا وين ما
[موسيقى]
بدهم